Congratulations, we're at the end of Lesson 2.
In this lesson, we looked at the App Engine
development cycle and how to create an App Engine
project. We also looked at Cloud Endpoints that allows
you to build a single backend that can work
with many different frontend device technologies. Together with Cloud
Endpoints, we explore the API explorer, that allows you
to test your backend and also other Google services.
And finally, we got conference central up and running in
your App Engine project, which is great, you've got a real
application running in the Google Cloud now. In Lesson 3
we have a look at storage. It'll be fun. Join us.